biscuits pancakes cookies cake and a
worldwide fungal infection HBO is the
Lassa versus A Thrill Ride for gamers
and non-gamers alike but those in the
know found some delicious surprises
hidden in the Show's first two episodes
spoilers ahead
in The Last of Us Part 2 Ellie tells her
girlfriend Dina that Joel's favorite
movie franchise is a Cheesy fictional
80s action series and she wants to use
it as an olive branch to help ease their
strange relationship what movie you guys
gonna watch let's draw into
uh Curtis and Viper 2. later in the game
while taking shelter with Dina and Jesse
in a Seattle theater Ellie notices at
Curtis and Viper four poster on the wall
in one of the back rooms and makes a
comment to herself that it was one of
Joel's favorites in the show fans will
notice that the DVD Sarah burrows for
Joel on his birthday it's Curtis and
Viper too a film that obviously holds
importance in their relationship so
what's the plot in The Last of Us Part 2
Ellie explains that it's about two
former Commandos that go Rogue to fight
bad guys and I think in Curtis and Viper
2 they go up against Russians spies or
something the young one Viper he's a
trained ninja and he's a complete badass
oh this is the one with the deleted
scenes yeah imagine about those ought to
be this Easter egg makes the impact the
franchise has on Ellie and Joel in the
video game much more dynamic as it
emphasizes what Ellie means to Joel and
how she has become a surrogate daughter
to him after Sarah's death Joel is
eventually willing to share his
interests with Ellie interested in one
shed with Sarah whose absence he felt so
much that he could barely talk about her
in the original The Last of Us
when players wake up as Sarah in the
video game they have the option to pick
up a birthday card in her bedroom the
card reads congratulations and features
an illustration of a green cartoon
dinosaur wearing a party hat Sarah says
that she
forgot to her dad but that worry is soon
overshadowed by the noise and Chaos
outside in the show there is a shot of
Sarah's bedroom and that same exact
birthday card can be briefly seen on her
desk underneath some art supplies the
inclusion of the art supplies in the
scene would mean that Sarah went to the
trouble of hand making her father's card
a neat detail left out of the game much
like in the game the shots of the
birthday card are not lingered on for
very long sadly Sarah forgets to give it
to Joel after gifting him his repaired
watch and falling asleep while watching
a movie together another neat detail
from the opening Sarah is wearing a
t-shirt for the fictional band halikin
drops in both the show and the game in
both versions the list of tour stops on
the back include several locations that
will be important to the story down the
road
one of the most infamous scenes from the
original game comes when Tommy Joel and
Sarah are attempting to drive out of
Austin amidst the outbreak when they end
up downtown Tommy's truck is totaled by
another vehicle as he infected attack
survivors and fires break out across
town which leads to Sarah injuring her
leg in the Escape fans were likely
expecting that very same outcome to
unfold in the show given how pivots all
this event is in the last of us and the
fact that the scene mirrors the
perspective players experience in the
game instead the writers change the
layouts of the scene opting to First
fake audiences out with an oncoming
truck that just narrowly misses Tommy's
truck the chaosa flips Tommy's truck and
the show does not stem from another
roadbound vehicle instead of plane
crashes in close proximity to Tommy Joel
and Sarah which leads to debris flying
at the truck and causing it to crash the
switch up gave the scene a fresh feel
and an episode that was largely faithful
to the original game
speaking of faithful to the game he has
an easy to miss more detail that fans of
the game likely picked up on when Joel
is forced to kill his infected neighbor
with a wrench he discards it likely out
of disgust for what he just had to do
with it but in The Last of Us game
series wrenches can be used as weapons
and the player is forced to discard them
all the time since they only have a
limited number of uses so switching out
Joel killing his neighbor Jimmy was a
fresh take that also nodded at the
mechanics of the game
the world of the luster versus plugs
into chaos after the cordyceps fungal
outbreak in the game it begins with
infected crops in South America however
the show takes on one of the main
sources of the spread Airborne Sports
and substitute Sam with 10 rules that
grow out of the infected Wallace and
clear so far there must be some
explanation for how cordyceps took over
the world in the show fan theories
circulating online suggests one possible
answer flower I was thinking we'd make
some cookies chocolate chip
reason Joel and Sarah managed to avoid
eating flower-based products at least
four different times in episode one
first they finally have run out of it at
breakfast and make eggs instead of
Pancakes later they politely decline
when their neighbor offers them biscuits
the same biscuits the infected neighbor
ate after that Sarah and Connie baked
cookies together but Sarah doesn't take
any because they have raisins in them
finally Joel forgets to pick up his
birthday cake after work beyond that the
creators of the show may have hinted at
all of this in The Last of Us podcast
their Craig Mason mentions that careful
viewers of this episode will be rewarded
repeatedly because little bits of
breadcrumbs have been planted that are
going to pay off later in interesting
ways plus it just so happens that the
world's largest Flour Mill is in Jakarta
which appears to be at the center of the
outbreak on the show Jakarta where is
that Middle East then ring a bell it's
definitely a country maybe part of Asia
Jakarta isn't a country fans will just
have to wait and see how these enigmatic
hints play out in future episodes of The
Last of Us dad love biscuits
I do
but I'm on Atkins when Ellie awakens at
the beginning of episode 2 a butterfly
hovers above her this is a direct
callback to various scenes in the
original game where Ellie is constantly
enamored by the beauty of the
butterflies and fireflies living outside
of the quarantine Zone butterflies
become a symbol of Hope which mirrors
the hope that the fireflies have an
Ellie's resistance to the cordyceps
virus which they think May hold the key
to producing a viable vaccine
scene any child born after outbreak day
is brought into a world of immense
violence and cruelty when Ellie is
falling in love with nature taking the
time to read comic books or cracking
jokes about the adults is a reminder
that she's still just a kid trying to
piece together some semblance of fun
amid a hollow and deadly reality on top
of all that before the events of The
Last of Us Part 2 Ellie gets a tattoo of
a butterfly to cover up the chemical
burn she gave herself to cover her bite
scar
um just so it's out there I can't swim
in the original game it's a running joke
and nuisance that Ellie can't swim in
numerous missions jolt is forced to push
Ellie across bodies of water using a
wooden pallet in The Last of Us Part 2
flashbacks show that Joel teaches her to
swim and she actually becomes quite
skilled at it she even gets good enough
to make a joke about her past
shortcomings and that's who encounter a
stray palette near a museum in Wyoming
no look
want to give me a ride
those days are long gone kiddos when
Joel test and Ellie reached the hotel in
Boston there is a lot of water
separating them in the stairwell they
need to get to quickly Ellie notes that
she can't swim because there aren't many
pools in the quarantine Zone annoyed by
her Point Joel shows Ellie that the
water only goes up to his knees it
remains to be seen whether or not
Ellie's inability to swim will become as
big of a plot points in the show as it
was in the game or if pallets will ever
come into play
in the game as Joel and Ellie are about
to reach the hospital in Salt Lake city
where the fireflies are stationed they
stumble upon a group of giraffes in an
open field it's one of the most
beautiful and enchanting parts of the
first game and it gives the player a
break from the never-ending brutality
players can stand at the ledge and watch
the giraffes for as long as they'd like
it's got its ups and downs
but you can't deny the view though in
episode two of the show has Joel Tess
and Ellie are traveling across Boston
and heading toward the capital building
they stop and take in the sights from a
rooftop you can't do another view
fragments of the same composition that
soundtracks the giraffe encounter in the
game are used to score the scene a
subtle link between the game and the
show hopefully we'll hear it again and
see some giraffes in a later episode
thank you